FEMALE SPEAKER: Hey.
So this Houston.
Houston was one of the producers
on the film.
HOUSTON KING: Hello.
Thank you all for coming.
We pulling in Andrew, too?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I think he said he would
be a little late.
Oh, wait, here he is.
HOUSTON KING: I think
here he is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hey.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hey,
how's it going?
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Hi.
Good.
How are you?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Good.
Yeah.
Everyone just watched
the movie.
That's what happened.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: That
happens sometimes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
know, it does.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: You'll
all be OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So it's a pretty loose
forum here.
If anyone has a question
and wants to ask it,
just raise your hand.
We'll throw a mic your way.
HOUSTON KING: Yeah.
Andrew, I might even say we're
sort of in the stunned silence
stage of one of your films.
Why don't you warm them
up a little bit here?
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Me
warm them up?
No, no, I mean, I think it's
nice to rest in the stunned
silence for a while.
Sometimes you just
need to close--
you can fall asleep in the
chairs if you want.
I don't know how long we have
the room for, but let it all
wash over you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Something
that was interesting--
I saw the film at Sundance,
and when you were talking
about the process for shooting
this, because it's 4:3, it's
clearly more analog than
digital, yet it's about a
digital topic-- do you want to
talk about that a little bit?
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Sure, yeah.
Well, I mean, we shot it on
40some year old video cameras,
and before I knew anything else
about this movie, before
I knew I wanted to make a movie
about computer chess
programmers, I knew
that I wanted to
work with this camera.
I'd seen some images.
There's some beautiful stuff
that William Eggleston, who
everybody knows as a
photographer, and particularly
a color photographer,
from Memphis.
But he shot some great stuff
on the Sony Portapak video
camera in black and white-- this
same family of old analog
cameras in the '70s.
And I saw some of that footage,
and it just blew my
mind wide open.
And I thought, here's a kind of
language of images that has
sort of disappeared
from the earth.
I mean, analog video was there
and widely used for a few
years, really, before the next
wave of video came along, and
we haven't really
seen it since.
But there's something so
specific and so beautiful
about how those cameras make
images that I just started to
fantasize--
you know, I'd been making movies
for 10 years shooting
on film, and for those 10 years,
people had been asking
me, well, why do you still
shoot on film?
Why do you still
And so I thought if people want
to see video, I'll show
them video.
And we found the prettiest,
weirdest, most
difficult video we could.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you
want to talk about--
I mean, I don't know how much
you guys are into workflow for
this stuff, but it was
actually pretty
interesting, right?
You guys had to basically build
out your own rig with
this camera that, obviously,
no longer is supported or
really around, right?
You got it from eBay, I
think you said, or--
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Yep.
Ultimately, we had three
cameras, because we could
never be sure how much we
could rely on them.
So two came from eBay, one I
think we were able to borrow
from a camera collector.
And we were really lucky.
Thank goodness I was not too
intimately involved in trying
to figure out how
to make it work.
That's kind of above
my pay grade.
But it does turn out to be
shockingly difficult, and I'm
sure some of your audience can
relate to the technological
woes of you take something that
was state of the art and
worked perfectly well 40 years
ago, and you think, well,
what's changed?
It should work perfectly
well now.
And it sort of does, but if
you want to get it to
communicate with current
technology-- if we want to be
able to show the film in a 21st
century theater the way
we just did-- there are an
incredible number of hurdles
that you have to overcome.
And so I thought this
would be simple.
I thought, well, we'll just
shoot it the way we would
shoot it in 1973-- just a guy
carrying around a camera.
Easy peasy.
But we ended up with this
ridiculous rig with 20 wires
coming out of the back of the
camera, and going to various
converter boxes, analog
to digital
converter, time based converter.
Again, stuff that I'm not even
sure what was happening.
But ultimately, we captured
the hard drive.
So using this very old analog
technology, we were still
making a very 21st
century movie.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Does anyone
have any questions?
Just yell them out.
Do you want to talk a little bit
about what inspired you?
And even on an acting front,
too-- like, what really
interested you about the
situation or the dynamics of
these people, or just this idea
of old school computers
doing mundane things?
Or I guess, very complicated
things that seem mundane.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Yeah.
I'm happy to throw
this to Wiley.
I think both of us are about
the same age, and certainly
grew up with kind of
spotty childhood
memories of this era.
And so I think there's a lot,
probably, that all of us were
drawing on subconsciously,
but happy to toss
that over to you.
WILEY WIGGINS: Who, me?
I don't know.
I mean, obviously there's kind
of a nostalgia element to
anybody who had these big,
clunky machines in their lives
when they were a child when they
seemed like the interior
of some kind of a rocketship.
But then, I think when you grow
up, there's this whole
idea of the utopian ideals of
early computer culture kind of
in some ways may have gotten
out of hand, and sort of
thinking about that
aspect to it.
Sort of like nostalgia mixed
with casting a critical eye
back at the origins of the world
that we live in today.
I don't know.
Is that fair, Andrew?
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Yeah, sure.
No, and I think a lot
of what I remember--
I remember in that era, when I
was a kid, that there were all
these philosophical questions
hanging in the air about what
is it going to mean as computers
enter our lives?
We all knew they were coming,
and so there was the kind of
utopian ideas about it, and then
there was all the fear
that went with it.
And to some extent, we have our
new utopian ideals and our
new fears now, and the
old ones seem quaint.
But I like the idea of
revisiting those old
questions, maybe
as [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well,
we tried.
Oh, wait, no.
WILEY WIGGINS: We lost you for
a moment there, Andrew.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Oh,
it was genius.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It was really
actually perfect timing as you
were talking about computers
in our lives, and all of a
sudden it was just
frozen in time.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Right.
Well, obviously, yeah, the
computer didn't like what I
was saying.
I thought it was pro-computer,
but who knows?
WILEY WIGGINS: I had a really
good time doing this, because
I had kind of a weird dual role
acting, and then also
helping doing some of the
equipment purchasing.
The machines that were still
functioning, we had to get
them to look like they were
actually executing computer
chess programs.
So I had to dust off my memory
of Commodore 64 Basic to try
and write some fake computer
chess stuff.
So that was super exciting
and fun.
I had a Commodore PET in my
house here for a while, which
was pretty awesome.
I don't know if you guys have
ever seen one of those.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Yeah.
It was very fun to hang
out with [INAUDIBLE].
And Houston sitting
there became--
I was surprised with how
obsessed you got with the old
computers, Houston.
You became a--
WILEY WIGGINS: Hacking
Houston King.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Hacking
You became a 1980s hacker
before our eyes.
It was amazing.
HOUSTON KING: I had to spend
hours upon hours writing this
program so they would run
on the screen, and I
was so proud of them.
And there's maybe about two
seconds of it in the film.
But I learned Linux, I think,
for a little bit, and a
couple-- what other languages
were we working in, Wiley?
WILEY WIGGINS: Well, all of the
stuff that was happening
on the actual computer was
Basic, but any of the stuff
that was sent over the serial,
I can only imagine what that
was coming from.
I'm assuming it was just modern
laptops that you were
just sending serial stuff to.
We were really lucky.
Actually, goodwill in Austin has
a computer museum, which
is a strange and wonderful
thing.
So that was a really good
source for a lot of the
machines that we found.
HOUSTON KING: Right.
And so we actually got
to go to the museum.
And we knew the teams that were
in the film, so there was
a corporation, there was MIT,
and then there was, like, Papa
George, who was on his own.
And so we would try to
correspond what the most
expensive computers with the
biggest amount of memory for
the corporations, and then work
our way down to what Papa
George's computer setup
would look like.
And luckily, they had so
many computers that we
were able to do that.
And ultimately, Czar, who's our
hero computer-- it's got
that very beautiful soft oval
face to it, if you will.
And it's even mainframe that
we use for that work-- the
exact ones at the time that were
the best computers, they
were using for computer chess,
just by pure coincidence.
We got lucky.
WILEY WIGGINS: [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: So it was a
Goodwill that had computers?
Like, a computer section?
HOUSTON KING: I've never
seen it before.
It was the Austin Goodwill
Computer Museum, and right
next door to it was just
regular Goodwill stuff.
WILEY WIGGINS: So it started
out because there was a
specific Goodwill computer store
here in Austin that was
basically selling old computers
that people had
brought in.
And just over the years, they
started getting all of these
really ancient machines, like
stuff that people were hauling
off from estate sales
and stuff.
And somebody finally had the
presence of mind to be like,
we should actually probably hang
onto and preserve some of
these machines.
So they opened up their little
miniature museum
alongside the store.
It's really cool.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: It's great.
It's a little one museum, but
then if you're granted access,
you can go back to the little
warehouse they have behind it,
which is huge, and full of all
kinds of beautiful old stuff.
And that felt like
the last scene of
Raiders of the Lost Ark.
We were just like, oh my god,
everything is here, and we
need it all.
And they were kind enough
to give us some of it.
And it was a real lucky
break for us.
HOUSTON KING: And similar to
the Museum of Moving Image
here, or even more similar to
the Goodwill Computer Museum,
there's the Museum of
Computer History
that's in the Bay Area.
I don't know if you've
ever heard of that.
Or there's another museum--
I think it's called the Museum
of Living History in Seattle,
which is just computer
museums.
And there's probably a lot more
that I'll find out about.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We have a little
mini one here on the
fourth floor.
HOUSTON KING: Oh, do you?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
ANDREW BUJALSKI:
That's awesome.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
HOUSTON KING: I want
to see it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
We can show you.
It's interesting, seeing all the
variations of computers.
At least for me, I only know
specific milestones, but I
don't necessarily know the
spectrum of all the
variations, so it's cool that
you guys were able to pull
from ones that actually existed,
and just be like,
well, one--
HOUSTON KING: I mean, for a
while, Radio Shack was all in
the computer business.
They had some beautiful
stainless steel computers that
they were selling.
And some of them are
in the film.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Some
of them worked.
Do you want to talk a little
bit more about--
some of the actors, I feel
like-- again, if I'm wrong,
I'm sorry, but do you want to
talk about how some of the
actors may have actually had
computing experience?
Like, Wiley, it seems like you
had a little bit as well.
Do you want to talk about
that a little bit?
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Sure.
Well, there are plenty of
folks in the movie who--
Gordon Kindlmann, who plays
Professor Schoesser, he is a
computer science professor at
the University of Chicago.
James Curry works with Wiley,
and they do video game
programming stuff.
And James-- the great thing
about James, who plays the
British programmer, Carbray, is
that he remembered all of
the '80s programming.
In theory, he's too young for
it, except I think he was a
child prodigy programmer.
So at age eight in Britain, he
was doing all this stuff, and
he knew at all intimately and
remembered all of it, which
was fantastic.
And certainly, Wiley knows a lot
of this stuff in and out
and up and down, and
it was hugely--
I mean, A, as Wiley mentioned
before, it meant that I could
doubly exploit my cast as
technical advisors.
But also, that I wanted
it to feel real.
If I'm going to make a movie
about computer programmers, I
want them to feel like
computer programmers.
And those guys to bring
so much more of that.
I'm not a computer programmer.
If I had sat down with Wikipedia
and tried to figure
out enough factoids to fill out
a script, and then handed
it to conventional actors, I
don't think we would've gotten
anywhere near it feeling right
the way that it does, or the
way that I hope it does.
And all credit is due to the
cast for that, certainly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Cool.
Well, how much did Weird Science
have something to do
with [INAUDIBLE]?
WILEY WIGGINS: It feels more
like Real Genius to me than
Weird Science.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Yeah,
that sounds right.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, that
actually makes sense.
Fine.
WILEY WIGGINS: There's a deleted
scene from this movie
where we fill the hotel
with Jiffy Pop,
heating it with a laser.
Little known fact.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: It'll
be on the DVD.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh.
Special features.
Do you have a question?
You can use this.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I had a question
about the use of VHS.
You mentioned William Eggleston
stranded in Canton,
and I knwo that Harmony Korine
cited that as a really sole
influence for Trash Humpers.
And I don't think there's
anything that's been written
yet, but I can totally see a
think piece being written in
the next couple years, like,
is VHS coming back, or that
sort of thing.
And I was just wondering if
you guys feel like VHS is
coming back, or maybe more
specifically, I was wondering
why it seemed to resonate
to you guys.
WILEY WIGGINS: Well, this
is way pre-VHS.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I guess I meant more the
Portapak stuff, too.
WILEY WIGGINS: Oh, right on.
AUDIENCE: I just meant
antiquated video form.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Well, I'd be
surprised if you started to
see this look take over the
multiplex, but I'd also be
surprised if this was the
last stunt like this.
I mean, to some extent, it is a
stunt, and certainly it was
this great leap off
the cliff for us.
On the other hand,
we meant it.
I mean, I hope the movie works,
and I hope it works
because we were using these
cameras for a reason, and to
produce a very specific kind of
feel, and to do something
very specific with that feel.
So yeah, I mean, it's open
for anybody to use.
I, of course, fell in love with
the cameras while we were
doing, and I started to
think, I want to shoot
everything on this.
Which I probably won't, but it
is a beautiful thing, and it
doesn't look like
anything else.
And you know, Trash
Humpers was VHS.
It was very much
its own thing.
It's hard to imagine that
on any other format.
So I just think it's
out there.
It's like any kind of palette.
It's very easy, certainly in
our current culture, for
people to get addicted to this
idea that whatever the newest,
latest, and greatest is is the
only thing you can shoot on.
And you see this all the time,
of course, that there are
camera fads, and I'm not
up to date with it.
A couple of years ago, at
least, people were only
shooting their movies on the
Canon, and I don't know if
they are now or not.
But for me, I just see all this
opportunity with all the
other formats that nobody else
is touching to say, what can
we do here that nobody
else is doing?
And that's kind of how I
approach any movie I make.
I hate the idea that my next
door neighbor might be making
the same movie.
I want to have some territory
to ourselves,
whatever that may be.
It doesn't have to be the
camera, but that's certainly
one way to get it something
unique.
WILEY WIGGINS: I was going to
say, also, if you're doing a
low budget period piece, it's a
pretty magical way to do art
direction for all the pieces
of the world that you don't
have control over.
You're applying this sort of
texture to everything that
makes it all work.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Absolutely.
We had a brilliant costume
department, we had a brilliant
production design department,
but we also had very limited
resources and very
little money.
And I think the camera goes a
long way toward bringing back
that late '70s, early
'80s feeling.
Because this is the kind of
image that you haven't seen
since then, so I think
it inevitably
transports people to there.
HOUSTON KING: And even beyond
just the issue of VHS, I find
the writers that we're talking
to about the movie are
incorporating writing about
the film as a bigger piece
about that we finally have
enough history and technology
that people are starting
to get nostalgic.
And seeing these pieces come
up about the old computers,
and even the gifs that we've
used to publicize the film,
and we're just starting to
finally see people looking
back at technology for
the first time
instead of always forward.
WILEY WIGGINS: Well, a new
tool doesn't necessarily
replace an old tool.
They all fill the toolbox up,
and you can go back in history
and pick things when they're
appropriate.
And that applies to technology
as well.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: But I can't
tell you how many sane and
rational people, when I talked
to them about doing this movie
on these old cameras said, why
don't you do it on a new
camera, and we'll do x y z
filter in post to make it look
like the old camera?
And that, on the one hand,
makes a lot of practical
sense, and on the other hand,
I'm so glad we didn't,
especially because this camera
brought so many weird, quirky
glitches in the movie that the
camera gave us that we never
would have been able to invent
ourselves that really, I
think, become very much a part
of the texture of the movie.
HOUSTON KING: And if you like
the look of it, there's
another example of a film that
just came out in theaters
called "No" that they used an
actual time period camera as
well, from, I think, it looked
like it was late '70s.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Something about the nuances of
when something doesn't work
that really kind of adds to the
overall aesthetic of any
film that's being shot with a
period camera that I think we
forget, because we just assume
that that's stuff you just
sort of glaze over.
But you're just used to
it at that point.
But going back, it's
very cool.
Anyone else have a question?
Yeah.
Should he be using that one
for the purposes of this?
Does it matter?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
It's possible that there are
whole genres of films about
conferences that I've never
heard of, but I was just
really struck by--
I've never seen a movie about a
conference before, and maybe
that was just a byproduct
of the topic that
you're talking about.
But it seemed so accurate and
true, but also depressing, but
also not depressing.
And I was just wondering where
the conference came from.
Like, is there a lot of movie
conferences that feel like
that, or how did that work its
way in, and how did it end up
being so realistic and weird?
ANDREW BUJALSKI: I'm sure a lot
of film festival memories
crept in there, because
certainly, you make a movie,
and you end up, if you're lucky,
and people want to show
it, then you travel around
with it, and you end up
feeling like--
I mean, I certainly remember
waking up in some of those
hotels and thinking,
like, I might as
well be a carpet salesman.
It's like, you travel around,
you kind of see the same
people, and say, hey,
how are you doing?
Here we are selling carpets
in Milwaukee.
All these people who--
we all like to think that we're
artists, but anyway, yeah.
I mean, that's the closest
thing I know
to convention culture.
But I've seen them.
I've certainly heard plenty of
great convention stories and
hotel stories from anybody who's
hung around these things
for any of their business.
Hotels are great, because
they're weirdly anonymous, but
also, they're so full of human
drama, but you never know what
that drama is.
It's all these secret
compartments of drama.
And it was so fun to get to
explore that and play with it
in the movie.
In some weird way--
I couldn't quite figure it out--
but the way that people
described early computers to me,
too, that the architecture
of the computer was much more
knowable than it is now.
And this fascinates me, that
at some point, I was lucky
enough to get on the phone with
Richard Garriott, the
video game programmer, and he
was talking about how when he
started out working in his
parents' garage, he knew
everything about the computer
intimately, and there was
nothing the computer did that
he didn't know what was
happening, because he'd
spent enough time with
it to master it.
And now, there's nobody
on earth.
I'm talking to you through
a MacBook Pro.
There's not a single human
being on Earth who knows
everything that's happening
inside of this computer.
It's gone way beyond the ability
of one person to
understand.
But something about--
and now I'm stretching a
metaphor pretty thin-- but
something about that
architecture of early
computers with all these kind
of knowable but unknowable
compartments--
I don't know.
Somehow, the hotel felt to me
like its own kind of computer,
or its own old computer.
Maybe an unbelievably enormous
hotel would be today's
computer equipment.
But I felt like there was some
weird cosmic resonance there.
I can't quite explain it, but
somehow, it helped with
whatever I was thinking in the
editing and the shooting.
A friend, Kevin Bewersdorf, who
plays the cameraman in the
movie, said to me after he
watched it-- he said, it's
like a drug movie made by
somebody who doesn't do drugs,
which is basically exactly
what it is.
So this is like, if some of my
thinking sounds a little
stoned, it's just me
trying to project
myself into being stoned.
I don't really do it that
much in reality.
WILEY WIGGINS: Timothy Leary
said that computers are the
new LSD, Andrew.
ANDREW BUJALSKI:
Who said that?
WILEY WIGGINS: Timothy Leary.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: There you go.
He should've known.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Any
other questions?
HOUSTON KING: There's one.
AUDIENCE: Howdy.
So there's that one shining
moment around the end where it
flashes to color, and there's
this old woman, and moments of
talk of religion.
It just seems like this strange
kind of anachronistic
hole, and characters get lost,
and they're never seen again.
And it was just a very
interesting moment, and I was
wondering if you could talk
about it a little bit more.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: I could
talk about it a little.
I think it sounds like
you saw most of what
was going on there.
You know, to some extent, we
were raising the ante so much.
In the last third of the
movie, as you noticed,
everything goes fairly insane,
and we're kicking everything
into as high a gear as we can,
and kind of throwing every
experimental impulse
at the wall.
First of all, there's an
incredible history of black
and white movies with color
sequences, and I think my all
time favorite is The Women
from 1939, which had this
amazing fashion show sequence
that just kind of comes in the
middle of the movie, and goes
color, and then it goes back.
But Raging Bull has one, She's
Got A Habit has one,
Schindler's List even
has the girl with
the little red jacket.
And again, it's always a kind
of stunt, but the question
with any stunt is, is there a
way to do the stunt that means
something, or that provides
some value?
And I like the idea, in this
case, that going to color
usually is about something
becoming grand or beautiful or
magical, and I like the idea
here that it was actually the
black and white footage that
really was our futuristic
footage, and to go into color,
we were really stepping back.
As you said, there's something
anachronistic about it, and
we're with this older woman.
And so this color photography,
which is in some ways more
familiar to us, although it
looks weird in its own way--
but we're stepping back from
1960s technology to 1930s
technology to shoot that.
And I liked the idea that that
color and warmth would be
somehow something
old and musty.
Which, again, is not an
explanation for it.
It's just one of the things
I enjoyed about it.
I can't explain anything.
It just is what it is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That
was pretty good.
That was good.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
WILEY WIGGINS: I just think he
couldn't bear to not have some
16 millimeter footage
in there somewhere.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: There's
that, too.
There's that, too.
For sure.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Anyone else
have any questions?
No?
You guys have anything
you want to say as
final remarks, or--
HOUSTON KING: Well, Jacob,
Jessica, thank you for having
us screen here today.
This is one of the very first
pure tech audiences we've
screened for, and so it was
very exciting for us.
And thank all of y'all
for coming.
And we open in mid-July at the
Film Forum, and so if you like
the film, please spread
the word and tell
people to come out.
Andrew will be here for the
Wednesday and Thursday when we
open, and Wiley, it looks
like, is coming Friday,
Saturday for more Q and As.
And so please come out, and you
can meet them in person.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Thank you
guys so much, yes.
WILEY WIGGINS: Thanks
for watching, guys.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, thank you
guys for joining us on the
Hangout, too, for chilling.
But yeah, thank you so much for
bringing the film here.
It's also great to see ways
that people interpret--
filmmakers, especially,
interpret technology, and what
people have done in the past,
and what they're doing now.
So that's rad.
Thank you.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All
right, guys.
See you later.
HOUSTON KING: See you guys.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Bye.
ANDREW BUJALSKI: Later.
FEMALE SPEAKER: See you.